la minute d'amour du centre commercial
place d'armes
la moselle est fixé à memphis et
l'affiné la vieille fille maman tu es la
fille soit et si votre maman était maman
en ce jour de fête des mères je tiens à
célébrer une femme non la force
m'inspire au quotidien elle est à la
fois on peut dire ma mère ma soeur ma
meilleure amie mon miroir mon père mais
aussi et surtout un pilier essentiel à
ma vie donc comme on dit toujours une
maman on en a qu'une donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut la célébrer tous les jours
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je lui
dis merci d'être un exemple pour moi au
quotidien que je laime et surtout bonne
fête maman je vais dire que j'aime mon
amant est toujours là pour moi quoi
qu'il arrive quand j'ai fait des bêtises
elle ne me punit pas annulée elle me
reprend et après je vais chez de la
faire plaisir en disant ça j'ai été bien
maman que je t'aime même fait des
merveilles
en vain
quand tu es sûr
marc ôter la fhf devait tourner quand
maman je t shirt vos fêtes des mères et
elle voulait souhaiter une bonne fête à
toutes les mamans de la martinique
c'est lui qui sont malades celles qui
sont couchés sur un lit d'hôpital a
enfin particulier à toutes les mamans et
je leur dis que je les aime
plein de bisous merci pour tout ce
qu'elle est maman pour les enfants les
nourrir les aider les accompagner pour
toutes les étoiles ont même fait des
marges et moselle beaucoup merci pour
votre attention
mais cet amendement moi aussi mais elle
m'a menti mais dès qu'ils m'accompagnent
de toutes les épreuves difficiles de ma
vie
bonne fête maman je t'aime de tout mon
coeur
passez de bonnes fêtes chatel
j'attends cette paroisse
bonne fête maman mon chéri d'amour que
j'aime alors une maman c'est le courage
le bonheur les émotions je souhaite une
bonne fête à ma maman que j'aime
beaucoup
longue vie à m
bonne fête des mères à toutes les mamans
et aussi les mamans qui sont déjà pas
bonne fée tél
bonne fête de l'eau à tout moment et
surtout un bobo au thème autant
bientôt maman à toutes les mamans
il ya vous êtes le bonheur à mouassa wap
les autres la gentillesse l'amour la
joie et le bonheur de tous les cas mon
père enfant pour ma mémoire
peut-elle la minute d'amour vous a été
présentée par le centre commercial place
d'armes